[Music]
you
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you
summer of chess comes to an end as 20
international grandmasters compete in
st. Louis u.s. chess champs calm
presents the third annual fall chess
classic hello and welcome back to the
2019 ball chess classic as always we are
your hosts my name is Caleb Denby I'm
joined by the wonderful Grandmaster
Denis for us all and we will guide you
through the games today well it's an
interesting round today it's round eight
the penultimate round of the fall chess
classic and it's the most critical ones
you know one of the most critical ones
in the B group things are still a total
toss-up but in the a group things might
be decided somewhat today so why don't
we actually take a close but we never
know you never know it's true you never
know about a round left after this one
one more critical round as well so why
don't we take a look and see where we
stand today in the a group standings so
ray Robson won his previous round to
bring him to five wins in a row which is
just incredible on you know on a scale
of this this level where all these
incredible in this this level yeah all
these players are fantastic chess
players world-class chess players and to
win five games in a row against any of
them is is ridiculous unheard of yeah so
that put ray one and a half points ahead
going into today jordan ven forest is
the only man that can catch him going
forward with four points out of seven
and then there are a few players all in
fifty percent still Lenderman Darrow's
roots fronting el camión and ilya smear
and all having very decent tournaments
on a level score and why don't we take a
look at the B group now yester Quesada
Perez actually lost his round seven game
which is incredible for the standings he
lost to Jack Shambu lyac who has now
tied him for the lead once again and the
NIC thing behind them is Aram Jaco
beyond yes around Maccoby and definitely
not one to count out as well as Manuel
Petrosyan actually the number one rated
player in the B group still trying to
make
some make some gains and catch those
leaders some ketchup yeah of course you
know jack has had an up-and-down
tournament he won the first three rounds
in a row and then uh slowed down a
little bit had a goblin grab it yeah
lost the game as well and then he
bounced back quite quite nicely
yesterday against the leader yeah circus
out of Perez well why don't we take a
look at the tournament format for this
event as we see the players roaming
around in the tournament hall up there
there of course to ten player round
robins that's the a group and the B
group the time control is 90 minutes for
the first 40 moves and then at move 40
they are granted an additional 30
minutes on the clock to finish out the
game there is of course a 30 second
increment for move one and there is also
a draw rule in effect switch there might
be some confusion on today so there are
no draw offers allowed before Black's
30th move so players are not allowed to
offer each other a draw however the game
can still be drawn two different ways
one is via stalemate and one is via
three move repetition yeah they repeat
three times then a player can claim a
drawing about three move repetitions
yes so we already have some some very
interesting news today ray Robson of
course the group a leader has already
drawn his game in a almost a
record-breaking 13 moves against his
opponent in the a group and so there's
some questions about how can this happen
how could reg Robson draw from moku Mian
two incredible players so quickly and
the reason for that is it it's just good
tournament strategy for ray-ray of
course is I had one and a half points
actually today we can still make a point
showing what happened so people
understand yeah why don't we take a
quick look look at the actual board here
so let's back it up to e4 e5 standard
c-45 classical open Spanish stuff and I
mean in fact open Spanish with me if 9
takes e4 would happen but Malcolm young
plays the classical line
it's kind of a deviation from the
marshal which is a big Armenian favorite
right that by their captain left
Aronian course so these six was played
c3 Castle d4 Ruki 895 and here where
what is putting pressure on the f7 pawn
black doesn't have time to play d5
because it was just open up too many
things on the f7 pawn so black has to go
back back and repetition ensues right
times repetition ensues and this is the
form of accepting a drop this is
completely within the boundaries of the
rules yeah absolutely and not only that
it really does make sense for right to
draw this round he saves his energy for
the what could be a critical game
tomorrow against your d'avin forest of
course the only player left who can
still catch him and he also secures his
position yet if if he draws today which
he has now Jordan has to win or else
tomorrow there's absolutely no chance
for yordan to catch away Robson at all
yeah so ray of course sitting very
nicely with his six out of eight score
it just makes sense to to do this and
talking about your damn phone forest yes
so what we want will be the game of the
day of God of course well we won't keep
you in suspense too long yes first of
all we'd like to thank you for for
joining us on social media as always get
involved in the YouTube chat we love
reading your guys's questions and
hopefully we can answer them a little
bit and you're also welcome to join us
on Twitter using the hashtag all chests
classic and lastly you can follow the
games for yourself live on us chess
champs calm you can jump to any game you
want then and take a look at wherever
the excite the exciting action takes you
well without further ado why don't we
take a look at the pairings for group a
Alexander Linderman is paired against
Darrow sweets
Alexander bort bort Nick takes on vara
Cobian Alex epitaph is facing Ilyas
Mirren ray Robson of course has drawn
his game against Randle cumin and what
was looking to be the key mashup of the
day but obviously that one has
ended without too much bloodshed and so
then lastly but not least Massif
Dhirubhai Li takes on Jordan ven forest
of course Wasif was off to an early lead
in the a group but has since struggled
quite badly to a to find his footing in
this tournament in the latter half here
we see of a thief a hard at work on the
board and what can your dudes day he
must win if he used to make a serious
bit for winning the sacred and it turns
out that both players went out one thing
some blood yes it makes sense for them
makes sense yes and so where do we stand
right now on the board so right now
actually black consolidated as far as I
guess he's an extra pawn from black yeah
but it's an opposite colored bishop well
it's not an endgame yet the Queen's are
still on the board but if was safe to
exchange it off it would land straight
into the endgame yeah and of course that
would be far closer to it to a draw
especially with this particular pawn
structure to be honest I still feel that
Black has some real winning chances as
the Queen's are still on the board right
and the attack might get real yes this
Bishop even though will attack this pawn
let's say Bishop b2 rook f7 now don't
forget the back rank trick it's
important this is an important thing to
keep in mind and the big deal here for
white is let's say queen e3 so you have
Queen g1 at the end and as I mentioned
before this wouldn't be such a great
deal for fun forest as this is probably
just going to be a draw because of the
opposite colored bishops right you need
the major pieces to make some threats
against the king so because of that
Bishop b7 makes sense and the big
question is is this attack enough for
black to win right and to be honest
there are some weaknesses back rank
stuff so I think that there's some
chances for black to win not that this
is not defendable for white yeah I kind
of agree the the nice thing about the
extra
is it actually does offer a little bit
of shelter for the black king as well of
course in opposite colored bishop
positions with other pieces on the main
factor to look out for is the Kings yes
because the bishops are operating on
entirely different colors that leaves a
lot of squares weak in the enemy camp
for example the g2 Square for white is
going to be his problem whereas
conversely the g7 square would be the
square for white to try to attack but
it's the dark squares will be blogs
Chris because of the e5 point as you
just mentioned this extra pawn does
offer that extra a little bit of shelter
for the black King and I also wanted to
mention and this is typical in this
structure which as you might not know
came from the knight Orff
the big issue here for white is if you
want to create a lift for the King
eventually so you don't get back ranked
the problem is that you can't really go
g3 because that's for one it's illegal
to it's not really desirable as I might
just build a deadly battery also so h3
would be the natural move but that
invites some tactical tricks
yeah the Futurist pin on Jeep honor can
be it can be problematic so what I'm
saying here is that force has a real
chances of actually converting
disadvantage but will he do it well ya
know it yet I've got to say I'm kind of
rooting for yordan here because it'll be
very very interesting to see him I have
to square off against Robson tomorrow
well if he wins he could force a playoff
in the a group and that would be a big
play off so then a potential candidate
for the tiebreaker is just about to make
a move and it looks like he's reaching
for that rook he chooses rook c7 rather
than f7 so he's in the second rank so h3
was played instead of Bishop b2
rook c7
so black is trying to jump at these
white square weaknesses and probably
there's the other reason this is so
comfortable for black because white has
to tend for all of these funds and
unfortunately for Dhirubhai Lee it's all
on white squares right definitely not
the easiest pawns to really keep track
of here so what does y do maybe I would
like to I would like to play a I don't
know what I would like to play probably
I should start with Bishop b2 eyeing
that that e pawn and asking you what
you're going to do about it so I could
attempt to exchange Queens but I'm not
sure if that's great on the other hand I
would get my rook on the second and not
sure yeah I don't know it looks it looks
rather difficult but maybe this should
be seven with the same idea and if the
rook and the bishop would work together
that would yeah that could be dangerous
let's say takes takes takes rook takes
c2 and combining the pawn pushes with
this g2 weakness I think this is real
winning chances for black here yeah
understandable
well why don't we take a quick look at
the group B pairings and see where we
stand there yeah of course we'll stay on
these players for a second longer as the
tension there is palpable
those players really playing for a lot
right now around the Cobian squares off
against the a circus nada Perez of betta
Gregorian takes on a Mon Hamilton
man well Petrosyan takes on Victor
Michalowski Jack Shambu lyac is having
to fight a very powerful Dennis
Catterick who is playing quite well
today and lastly and what is our key
matchup of the day Stevens Erick is
playing Alexander fear and actually I
just got some breaking news in my ear
Alexander has actually won this game and
he's coming down soon so why don't we
get him in for an interview and he can
tell us about that game while you know
maybe introduce the opening yes so a
very nice win by Alex under fear
bringing his Kings gambit ear
attitude to the game and also some funky
stuff in the opening now a six is not
the usual line that you normally see
normally you would see these six which
would lead into the night or f-- per the
game to reveal a fun forest which was
Bishop g5 e 6f for Queen b6 and this
classical poisoned pawn variation but
that's under fear came up with a
different way of playing I I've seen
this move before and I think the highest
ranked players I've seen playing this
one was rapport and mores evich but the
man himself is here to explain if it was
just following footsteps or you had
original ideas prepared hello it's hey
it's decelerator neither you're stopping
Bishop b5 forever then I avoid the
furrows and d4 yes because this is the
big trick now you can go be 5
immediately as far as I know and you
have this active planning like this I
think very comfortable but obviously
everybody knows that you can't do that
why unfortunately so c3 was late so did
you expect this and then decided to go
for a 6 or this was some sort of a
preparation well actually I saw this
when I started to see this line when
once I was going to play against you via
covertly huh and he was always going c3
mm-hmm
and I was going to play against it real
move to a6 I'll try to transpose the
disposition and look at the language
with d5 when Quinn takes d5 I think
they're a bit worse for black but this
gambit is interesting yeah it's very
interesting the way you play it Queen
takes d5 is the other line which is
slightly worse yeah but Knight f6 and I
like this idea because this feels a lot
like you're playing this Portuguese
variation exactly so the Portuguese if
you don't know is this one Knight f6 d4
here if I'm correct
here and II six yeah and then black has
big compensation for the pond and okay
in my case the pond is not going to do
for so easily
yeah it's even worse for why that's what
TV echo played actually mm-hmm and okay
what has many ways to keep this pond up
it can play like even without c4 if he
plays d4 it's still like many ways to
keep this pump of 34 CD forty can go.you
Derek we need for check or see for both
both for winning about yeah so this
looks like a young variation how young
is this I never see I've seen a six but
I haven't seen many games in d5 Knight
f6 no it's my normal openings were not
working figured this might be played for
95
strangely I think it is improved version
for black of panel yes
the bishop is open on c8 compared to the
normal line and it's in this thing okay
maybe in three Bishop c4 I can play
anything so for example here if Bishop
the tracking will be shop c4 uh-huh and
it it's nice for me and if Bishop c4 I
have this Bishop e6 yeah so basically
you enter the pawn off with a knight on
d5 usually is supposed to have v6
instead of five yeah so Bishop c4 and
Bishop e6 was a very nice move yeah
following the footsteps of the previous
game between Tirupati and Robson or at
least very similar and actually it's
interesting because I've seen similar
ideas with reversed colors but wouldn't
see this exact position where black
would actually put the bishop on e6 so
that's the point of Bishop e6 for
example there is an interesting line
here that is not g5 directly uh-huh and
that takes c3 bishop takes c6
oh nice matte d1 Bishop f7 King deservin
Bishop e6 and King c7 know what King d6
is not too good because a Bishop f4 and
that King has some trouble so King c7
and you start running yes
like bishop at for architects new one
and it's a mess huh yeah yeah who knows
what's going on but I kind of
disciplines although what if d5 have
those might be 4 into 5 and yes you give
a check but so what mm-hmm yeah so this
is a crazy position but okay in last
case I can go King g8 back and yeah and
it's just a perpetual it looks like
there's a queen's gambit accepted yeah
yeah exactly that that repetition line
so Bishop b3 was played 1595 you're
taking a hold of this game okay there is
a friend of mine Oh Debbie play this
position and won some easy game and then
I tried later against one camping in
some rapid game and okay because if I
take on b3 black is just fine yeah you
will I guess just go g6 Bishop g7 castle
and what could be a browser if Bishop
City I can do the same mm-hmm it's a
terror that you're dreaming of you're
playing it with reversed color so that's
the best thing on this planet yes an IG
v obviously Zook is trying to do
something yeah it was about Knight takes
c3 and Bishop d5 or Bishop c4 but the
problem of Bishop c4 he can change in
connect rate and they have problems it
might be annoying tough Bishop the five
is possible to play but I didn't want to
take on c3 if I'm not forced yeah and if
he takes it just take it back you take
on b3 so Bishop c2 Bishop g4
did you consider taking and then moving
the bush I thought about this too but I
thought like
I can probably go something like we
should pay three maybe yeah so should be
okay too but the the Bishop c4 is more
provoking huh yeah and actually you know
that that's very committing mm-hmm now
it's very likely the game will be
decided we should have five and yeah the
problems I guess this night and this
Bishop is misplaced yeah he can always
go 94 but if I manage to complete with
the six Bishop e7 Castle fine so we
should have five Bishop e4 takes age six
just asking some questions and yeah only
about these six instead of going to be
five but I think in some lines the queen
is misplaced on a five he should it
should be on the seven defending the bow
so I thought maybe here he had rook be
one threatening Queen eight four check
and this is a bit annoying because I
have no good way to defend the pawn hmm
so couldn't be five I lose one temple
but at least survive what castle for the
moment yeah
and I mean the main problem with these
panels positions with might that your
structure is horrible yeah so if you
don't win before move thirty you're
going to suffer the rest of the game so
for example I'm not afraid of Queen e2
or yeah because these end games are just
so much fun for black and and suffering
for white especially that black is going
to go rook c8 and c4 will never ever
happen
so King F to e6 we should before you say
no check maybe you try something with
rook e1 and define something more active
but I think that I should be fine doing
so sometimes we tricky one Bishop e7 d5
can maybe go rook da to look the ATS is
also possible probably ever play this
yeah but this five in the fede 596 is
coming and King f8 and even like this is
not that clear because now you have five
Bishop c5 and but I didn't want to like
let so much grain oh so maybe white is
dreaming for something like this
so rooky won't work there just a small
car that furniture looks a bit slow I
think the no like in the game instead of
fruit yeah
Queenie choose a little slow should be
seven and you're not gonna let see
happen
and after this is I think it's kind of
clear I think if I play caso and he goes
before I'm still slightly better but
there is absolutely no reason to want it
yeah so b5 is the most ambitious yeah
92 looks nice trick unfortunately it
doesn't work but it's a nice idea
so a4 and he said thank you for the part
because if I can so at least he got rid
of one of the weapon yeah yeah and if
you can at least start exchanging the
queenside then there's some hope of
surviving and the point is after take
queenie phifertex g7 and no yes so this
is very very interesting and here not
very I think because if Queen g7 well I
can go all night see why and if he takes
on h8 King to 7 and 93 is coming and c3
is hanging and you don't want to come
back because yeah you get an unwelcome
fork and if you just do rook takes you
one instead of Queen h8 sacrificing the
exchange thinking the 7 anyway and the
night cannot go to e5 so yeah there's no
problem yeah and again this f3 pawn the
big issue so anyways let's go to the
critical moment I guess the Bishop f6
was missed by Steven and you know he has
no good way to get the bit rebound yeah
and now you just defend everything if
you go here I assume we should be 7 you
just kick the clean-out yeah and after
this it's kind of like smooth sailing
yacht upon well the the endgame required
some calculations later but I was
confident that he chose me because white
has too many weaknesses here yeah it's
like he had like instead upon on sheet 2
instead of d4 yeah it would be much some
chances yeah so yep and this was a
straight forward to be careful that when
they change all the paths for him to not
sacrifice the route can take the
and a six yeah that's why I had to make
this kind of slow plan yeah thank you
six yeah yeah so a nice little win you
put the rope behind the pond as thought
it's still I cannot I cannot he has this
idea for oxy 300c well rook she won
worked extra - mm-hmm but the time long
time but you're just in time to bring
the king closer and win
very nice win thank you so maybe that's
why you should you're supposed to play
the Kings gambit and gives you extra
boost of confidence and then luck
returns to your side again yeah now that
I come back the tournament is finishing
yeah well we should ask some extension
for this let's add three more round
in any case congratulations and very
good luck for the last round thank you
yes we might want to look at Stamboul
EOG's game at the moment as dramas
incoming Istanbul iakh seems to be in
trouble as Cade rich did the Wardrobe
gambit changing from the purple hoodie
for some more casual wear if you look at
this position we can notice that white
does not enjoy the two rooks
but the knight and rook which is
traditionally a verse constellation
Caleb what do you think who would you
rather be here well generally I think
that rooks are worth more than Knights
and you know I think that uh that's a
good philosophy holds true here and
Venice has quite quite a nice positions
Godrich has some very nasty threats set
up here on the other hand let's not hate
on the night this is a powerful night
supported by the pawn but unfortunately
for Jack Stamboul iakh it's really not
doing too much right there's no
potential jumps because this structure
is well defended and this rook alone
will not checkmate the black kings and
and black has this extra pawn
just as the kicker yeah just as a kicker
so this looks fairly bleak for a white
oh yeah I definitely agree maybe he was
just feeling a bit too light-hearted a
bit too happy with with his colourful
hoodie and what he needed was some more
serious clothes to bring down the pain
on his opponents sore for a serious
business serious clothing of course all
right so this game is actually huge
fruit for the B group if Jax were to
lose this game
that gives you a circus out of pres the
chance to come back and at least take a
half point lead with the draw and even a
full point lead going into the last
round if you were to win this that's
talking about B group rivals yes Quezada
how play is playing black against Aram
Jaco byung yes so this is another very
relevant game to the B group standings
and as we see a COPI on Hawk opion is
actually under some pressure not that
it's too big of an advantage right but
let's say if like to play rook c4 piling
on this C pawn eventually the truck c8
black is in no danger of losing yeah I
agree
white has a weakness on c3 and once
again it seems like I say it about every
endgame but I really hate having the
weaker King in that game so it just
makes everything so much more difficult
in this kingdom h2 is by far a lot
weaker than the King 9 g8 so I think
that objectively are on how cobia might
be able to draw this yes but from
experience I can tell you you can't say
it's a drawn position but you still have
to survive five more hours of suffering
exactly and yeah these players have
shown a very they're very much willing
to go into those six hour games yes just
to really grind home try to get that
full point so what's our current
position on the board actually is this
Oh actually it's not it's rook GE one
that was the last move played okay so
I'm just suspecting book c4 is coming
next tied it up on this pawn and I think
it's black to be preferred here yeah
let's let's uh let's analyze
because in that position you had on the
board I thought maybe black had a tactic
so Rick's e4 is logical I'm yeah I think
queen takes c6 makes a lot of sense rook
takes and then you wanted to play Bishop
d4 here yeah I was wondering if I could
get away with Bishop b2 and just taking
this pawn can I go here oh yeah I was
going to capture here and Rick a B or C
8 rather Rick a CA I'll take you take
take take take take and check my age
check out draw at the end of the game or
at the end of the line you get the game
yes but actually maybe Quezada wouldn't
be too upset with a draw as that would
propel him into clear first base yeah
very true although I think in a position
like the one that he has now he is no
danger of losing so no reason to go
directly into the draw line however it
might make sense to trade off the guys
just eliminate your risk that's true but
sometimes you want to secure the
situation and yeah so far this looks
very good for Quezada all right we'll
have to keep an eye on this end game see
what yes or quesada Perez can do but in
the meantime why don't we jump over to
the a group I think Barra Kobe and
actually has quite an interesting game
going on okay let's take a look at that
here we see var there with his eyes
almost shut it seems but you know
thinking hard at the border yes and in
fact as I can see whites blundered nine
things d4 which is probably hmm yeah its
disaster because probably white saw that
okay this checkmate there's not a big
deal I'll be able to defend that but
there's gonna have to but this leaves
the the night behind yes so is white
simply losing now by this simply losing
Wow and she's looking at looking at
important icon over the board he had in
his hands for a moment day he's clearly
a little bit distressed about hanging
this shaking his legs yeah you can
you can feel the pain I feel it I feel
it through the screen the pain meanwhile
bar leans back as though I'll take a
free punch yes
why not three pawns is my life so so the
Det var were to win here he would
actually go up to oh just fifty percent
four out of eight I thought this might
bring him to it to a positive score but
Bart himself has actually had a rather
up-and-down tournament yeah I'm losing a
very nice game by Ray Robson yeah and
probably that was the critical game that
kind of put some pressure on a Cobian
tournament yeah definitely um needed to
score there to have a decent chance at
the top prizes yeah but I mean to be
fair ray Robson has been putting
pressure on everybody's tournament in
the past I've had a five in the mid of
the tournament that's that's worth class
stuff it's incredible
so talking about class stuff let's get
back to the game of the day alright how
is the game of the day doing here and
between Dhirubhai Lee and your inventory
and it seems that your Dhin is piling
some pressure under by Lee and you can
even see on the gestures just look at
that art by Lee kind of observing
reluctantly of what's going on you get
this this interesting body language yeah
a player who's pressing starts to lean
forward and the players defending starts
to lean back and then they kind of go
back and forth and this one like white
seems to be just observing from a farm
more like daydreaming not anymore
but he did now both is both others are
back in tank jordan redoubles his
efforts leans even further over the
board wants to make sure is that his
opponent can see and Jordan is in deep
calculation you can sense that he's
eyeballing the G to pawn really hard
yeah definitely he's just gonna stare at
it until it falls off the board i Hank
is this plan notice Jordan's hand
gestures some players would even start
moving around actually showing the
direction of the calculation right
and I just want to stress the importance
of this game Jordan Forrest if he wins
today he has a chance to force ray
Robson into a playoff tomorrow
however with anything but a win this
will decide the tournament ray Robson
will be your group a champion if your de
not pull this off so Jordan has a
substantial time advantage as well he
has 20 minutes against 8 yes always
always nice to have that in your back
pocket
10 more moves to make and if black and
he's about to make a move of course
these are not easy moves for white as
well black is creating some very serious
yes and as I said there's just a lot of
weaknesses in White's position and as we
all know if you want to win a game you
need to have at least two weaknesses in
your opponent's position right in fact
White's position is even more unstable
than that because potentially this King
could also get under some heavy attack
so I still think that is fun for us for
the win alright and yeah we see Queen g6
get played and now why don't we stick
around and see what Missy fizz is going
to do about this LightSquared a my
secret attack queen g6 is a really
strong move why well because it's not a
one move threat it actually sets up
threats multiple threats so black might
eventually want to go Bishop b4 and hit
this c2 pawn also this Queen on e 2 is
tied down cannot ever take because g2 is
checkmate immediately and you can really
try to block this Queen from attacking
this pawn because the c2 pawn would drop
yeah exactly some uncomfortable threats
most liked it they think Bishop b2 runs
into heavy tactics heavy tactics heavy
tactic oh my goodness how heavy very
heavy very heavy heavier than that
statue in front of the Hall of Fame
heavier than that statue in front of the
Hall of Fame well and I'm not sure I
catch your meaning what
tactics are you referring to first of
all six six ah okay
and I take I call Bank and I take all
your pawns so you found the heavy
tactics even heavier than the world's
largest chess piece exact kind of the
Hall of Fame okay well uh while of
asifa's considering his options here of
course queen g6 is a very nice move to
make well your opponents and time
pressure you know you you let him decide
okay I'm setting up these latent threats
you can decide how you want to defend
but I'm going to give you options I mean
you have choices to make instead of a
very forcing line which she can kind of
blitz out very quickly and notice that
the raw body is in heavy tank now if we
can have a close-up on him he has some
issues dealing what to do now and in
fact this is what you should be aiming
for when you're playing chess posing
difficult problems yes very difficult
problems indeed however in the B group
some difficult problems have not been
posed and that game we were just looking
at between a circus out of Perez and a
rhombic Obion they have actually agreed
to a draw after exceed four perhaps
black had in mind some of those lines we
were looking at yes so it's going to be
three versus three look-see robust
played and that as we expect that
probably they thought that this Bishop
b2 Ryan is just a draw rare and I think
we tend to agree that that it is yeah
not a whole lot to play for if there
were to go down this line maybe yes or
had some other options to keep the game
going but it's good tournament strategy
for him to take the draw here yes he has
that advantage going into the final
rounds and it puts all the pressure on
the people chasing him to try to make
something happen
both Aram Huckabee on and Jack stamboli
AK actually Aram hakugen is not far off
from yeah run only a half point behind
yes or after it is he playing in the
last round
ah that is an excellent question and
we'll have to get our researchers as he
might be the surprise of the tiebreaks
yeah as he might sneak into
we've a tie yet the talk of the
tournament so far has been a circus out
of Perez and Jackson Bulli ik but now
Rondo Cobian just a half point out of
the lead going into the final round and
anything could really happen and this B
group still meanwhile the other B group
game that we should definitely be keep
an eye on is this game between Jackson
Billy Eck and Dennis Kendrick Dennis
seems to be very very close to actually
winning this game and if Dennis were to
win that would essentially knock Jack
out of his chances at winning in this B
group and so it would really just be
down between yessir and Andy Rama Cobian
so some moves been played here
Mook cb6 so stamboli I couldn't really
find a useful move so decided to take a
pawn fair enough which is a fair choice
would be to be nay too and if you can
ever do this to post your heavy pieces
on the second-ranked okay pressuring
this f2 pawn because if that falls the
game is literally over yeah and in fact
the it's tough to see what white would
do if black simply played rookie 2
rookies e 2 and then checkmated the way
it came yes so rule D to Ruby B 2 and a
very strange version of the Alekhine's
gun would show up yes the the lateral
the lateral Alec is gone sure very nice
and so yeah it done is actually playing
a bit of a spoiler in this tournament if
he manages to defeat Jack today which
I'm expecting him to he spoils Jack's
chances at winning and tomorrow a Romney
Cobian will actually have to face the
man in the purple hoodie who took the
purple hoodie off to win today because
Dennis will be getting a chance to spoil
the roms chances at the tournament title
tomorrow as one only but I think it will
be a splendid matchup because I would
expect fireworks there as both players
seems to be fairly ambitious yes Todd
which seems to be yeah yeah well this
Dennis business Todd which seems to be
yet some of the most exciting Chester
yeah he's playing the most exciting
chess at the moment and
I'm assuming that both of them will be
ready to fight and in fact talking about
fighting if my boo playbook c7 here BAM
and rookie - and even if you would give
a check that wouldn't help you as III is
coming blocking this diagonal also
signaling the end of the game
it's ripping up in the white king all
the rook rook and Queen invading
certainly a lot of problems for ejection
to leak to solve and it just seems this
does feel like dennis is likely to win
this game all right well what games are
you interested in checking out Dennis
let's take a look at India's Mirren's
game absolutely yeah let's actually
start from the beginning so this was
nice to start yes
always the best place to start the
beginning so this game was played
between Alexey fought off and Ilyas
mirin and as we known alias screen just
won his previous game against bortnik
ran splendid modern modern game
absolutely where he just smashed the
modern so as predict as we could all
predict and almost he kind of hinted at
that that when I said that he's an
expert at the Benoni
he said no no I'm a King's Indian player
no it comes all right the King Edward II
v and others h3 line is it's quite
interesting for us so d5 is the
ambitious move yeah but Alexi part of
took on e5 boom
and now Elias mirin is going to show how
do you play for a when if there's going
to be lots of exchanges right so Queen
d8 rook takes 96
this is a typical Kings Indian play
black is not afraid to lose upon if he
can get some active piece play going
yeah of course ID 5 56 a typical way of
defending the knight otherwise it would
lost
thanks Brooke c1 so if takes I have
rookie six and I have good pressure on
your position right so rook c1 bishop d8
and this is an interesting thing lots of
players are reluctance to put the bishop
back but I've seen many great Russian
Grand Master's and the US Champion
namely gata Kamsky yes famously talking
his bishops away and using it to full
effect 15 moves later yeah especially
early on in the game the bishops are
kind of susceptible to being attacked
you'll see a lot of openings like if a
bishop comes to c5 or f5 very often like
a knight appears on h4 attacking this
Bishop trying to harass it trying to
take it off the board and bishops being
a long-range piece can perform just the
same tasks just as well from far away
yes so this bishop does a good work of
defending and defending against any
potential jumps and it's unattackable
yes from da it's on a saleable @ d8 c5
rookie 6 a3 c6 takes so white is kind of
exchanging as many pieces as possible
but beware of the latent power of the
bishop there he takes rook e7 f5 and to
be honest with you I still consider this
a big success for black as Elias Miran
still has the bishop pair on the board
and an unbalanced position where black
has the majority on the King Salva white
has the majority on the Queen side right
so in fact I think if part of didn't
manage to clarify the position enough
and Ilya smearin is going to start
playing for a win here okay we should be
v King f8 who they want rook b8 and the
sad part when you don't have the bishop
there you don't have the luxury of
opening up the position because that
would just let the dragon out as any any
opening of more diagonals more files
real
favors the bishops rather than this
knight on f3 which is not really making
a good impression yeah at the moment but
if white does not open the position
black will have enough time to develop
the pieces out right before Bishop c7
notice that the smearin is making sure
that all of his pawns are well defended
and he goes from there 90 to Bishop d7
everything's protected now we can
develop Bishop e3 e4 no more pressure
you will never go back to f3 Knight C
for Bishop e6 opposing this Bishop and
this Bishop is kind of happy there as
it's again very hard to get close to
that as this rook will have trouble
breaking through this locate on e4 will
be one be six eventually black has to
open up the position otherwise the
bishops power will not be felt
especially this Bishop needs more spec
squares c6 trying to close it up but no
B 593 takes takes rook e6 and look how
much smear his position improved he has
a clear majority in the center
ready to roll while also there's a
potential weakness on c6 yep he has
targets
he has future plans of creating a passed
pawn with f4 and e3 everything looking
up for it first here in here so since
the 12th move when we exchanged and got
the bishop there we've had 16 extra
moves and it looks a lot nicer for black
yeah this is the power of just playing
logical chest clear chess Elliot didn't
do anything special he just made sure
his pieces were defended and he played
to his strengths he pushed his majority
up in the center and he improved his
pieces but by but yeah so rook seafood
rook c8 latent Lee threatening it so
probably Bishop b6 or Bishop b5 is also
on the cards now g3 there should be six
as predicted lots of pressure on the c6
spawn now Luke c1 Luke d6 you give me
the file I'll take it
absolutely looking f1 bring in the
king's king d8 and sadly for whites this
pawn
I have the feeling is going to fall
sooner or later let's say a six black is
bringing in of course the King as the
third attacker that he needs to take out
this pawn and there's a save King
position on c7 a firm control on the D
file the only thing left that black
needs to do is to prepare the march of
the black pawns uh yeah it's very
important as well that the be pawns are
still on the board that could become
relevant a lot later in the game if
white ever is considering trying to get
rid of all of the pawns on the Kings
side there's still these be pawns that
he has to worry about yes this is a very
instructive game so far by Elias mirin
how to try to get the maximum out of
like a fairly even position right and I
gotta tell you tennis as as the player
with the white pieces I do face the
Kings Indian quite a bit and it hurts me
to see people playing these boring lines
where they they take on e5 and then try
to place them in game don't they know
that opening losses by force you just
have to win on the Queen side
black will never checkmate you if you do
everything correctly just play perfectly
and then win the game it's not so hard
yeah it's no wonder I said that d5 is
the main line yes if they give you the
center take the center yeah that's
that's the way to do it in my opinion
but okay Elias mirin is showing a lot of
a logical chest a lot of very simple
very strong chess so talking about
logical chests let's take a look at Alex
Len durman's game between him and Doris
where's right both of these players
having a very decent tournaments in
their group both on 50% still hoping to
make that last little push into a very
good tournament with these last two
rounds so let's back up a little bit to
the critical position here
here why decided it's time for some
action okay
and we already learned what we're
supposed to do if we have the bishop
pair in Elias Mirren's game and now we
can guess what Lenderman will do alright
well clearly move and play you have to
open it up and there are a few ways to
do that here d4 with his choice of
course if he takes D you never capture
that pawn back with the e pawn that
would be ridiculous closing the center
but in fact tactics is always in the air
that's the way to do it and I think d5
is a very nice move by Alex Thunderman
the point being you can't really get an
advantage from taking on d5 as Queen d4
sets up a double threat of attacking the
knight and preparing mate on h8
checkmate is dangerous so Knight f6 was
played takes on f6 takes takes knight b3
and it's not really over because even
though white has the bishop there the
advantage will be on one side of the
board and it's never easy to convert
that of course so rook takes e8 was
played as this Knight is attacking this
c1 rook takes takes bishop b7 if they
give you the pawn for free take it okay
Ruby it takes root B 1 a for Bishop c6
and now the a for pawn is falling but
here it's plays very nice move yes
I hate it when you do this and I have to
come up with a very nice smooth is this
very nice move rook b6 taking off one of
the bishop pair yes all right
and it's tricky sometimes you fall and I
see many players forgetting about these
threats yes this is what happens when
you don't play like la smear Aliyah
playing very carefully making sure his
pieces are defended unassailable yes if
you put pieces on squares where they're
undefended you're going to run into
tactics no matter what position to this
so white is still better but it's an
opposing colored bishop and game rights
but rook still on the board but it's
very
hard to make heads and tails of how to
win this and actually I think Black
improved more on his position than white
did as this is probably the maximum you
can get trying to put pressure on the f7
pawn right but black just sets up on the
dark squares this bishop actually the
bishop in the King together can nullify
this rook by blocking any of the files
and it's it's not going to be a lot for
what yeah I think I still assume white
should have tried go King G to G for
King g3 f4 and try to get try to somehow
force black to sacrifice the bishop for
all the pawns and hope for a Brooke
Bishop versus rook and game which is at
all but it takes a lot of efforts for
the defender to actually hold and
perhaps we will still see that it's
later to come in this game maybe but I
feel that white did miss his chances of
actually getting there as his bishop is
much worse placed on c2 then it was on
b3 right yes very very difficult to win
effort from Lumina I definitely agree so
let's see what's going on in the key
game between do not believe a thief of
course and more than fun for us and oh
no I don't like what's happened in this
you don't like what's happening I don't
like it at all
I don't like it at all i I've seen
optionally bishop end games before I
have tried to win many obstacles bishop
end games
I've tried to lose many opposite colored
Bishop end games somehow no matter how
good I play how bad I play it's always a
draw
alright so let's let's take a stab at it
hmm so we don't want to give away this
pawn I assume certainly not let's put it
on the square where this guy can't put
pressure on us okay so potentially if I
can start running with my king up to c4
and nurse this pawn maybe I can win it
is two pawns for it for black here but I
don't really see this happening if you
play g6 I see what do I want to do maybe
we won the King on d4
to stop this d5 invasion don't we yeah I
definitely agree so yeah King III will
start with me so okay King e6 king d4
big question is if I can start harassing
your pawns on the other side so h5
wouldn't make sense cuz let's say here
takes takes it and then I'm getting
closer to it draw question is yeah I
should fix these pawns so I could go
here and take why don't we go back to
that starting position you play g6 here
maybe black is actually considering the
slightly counterintuitive GE v e5 fixing
his pawns on dark squares but fixing his
opponents on light squares yes and so
hoping later on maybe for a bishop f1
idea and indeed was played g5 was played
Oh
fixing the pawn on g4 and h3 so okay I
think King I wouldn't want to let this
pawn go down to e2 certainly not I wanna
go King III yeah and what else to do
besides a bring bring the King forward
so I might try to eat all the pawns that
you give me before it's too late
fair enough this looks problematic but
if you go go chasing my pawns maybe I
have time to play a 5 ok I I take wait
takes okay I take it okay don't think I
have time to play King f6 because then
you can play Bishop f8 and is really yes
your only plan basically so I must
continue with b4 I take I will take back
will I take back you will be I guess I
will take Nick like this doesn't really
help you I can just come back uh yes the
only point would be its it's farther
away from my other pond so be more
difficult for your King to catch yeah
well this case I need to get rid of your
Beach yeah you need to get rid of my
pawn takes
King before so I'm kind of planning to
use my bishop here now I can play King
f6 though and you're only getting one of
my pawns in the king size 8 and I think
I've made real progress on the Queen
side here ah
I have to play b3 and King c3 or Bishop
a3 I will go ahead and let's see what
will I play a thing I built a fortress
you've built a fortress because even if
you go here I just wait and you can only
go back and forth and I will never move
my king you will never move your king
yes is that so you want to test it so
I'm just trying to make obviously I
think blacks only idea is an eventual
Bishop f1 to h3 but so the problem with
that is your king is in time to defend
your jeep on as well so I will defend my
pawn in due time so I think let's go
back g5 I think that should have been
equal unless you have one yes it was
continued just a little bit further that
you have in that final position there
mm-hmm black you're saying black can't
win this position what if I play King
FIF and I just bring my King over to the
Queen side are you going to be able to
take my Jeep on without living yours
behind it bishop f1 okay Bishop b5 will
say just for fun okay
yeah and Bishop d7
and now I will come king defiance and
then a little bit of a switcheroo okay
you pulled the switcheroo on me yes
so you're just in time I'm Justin time
very unfortunate these bishop and games
are tricky like I said somehow no matter
how well I play how poorly I play it's
interesting yes oh so so the current
position the current position is king g3
which I don't like
honestly Wow so now a difference here is
you know in all those lines White was
able to give up these tempi with the
pawn at the right mo yeah whenever black
could advance a pawn white was getting
something very serious in exchange for
it here black can advance upon and all
White's going to be able to do is I
guess trade off one of the pawns with H
4 but so I'm not sure that's enough to
adjust off' i allowing this again let's
take a look at the players look at those
gestures yes you think
well you're the psychologist here denna
do you think Jordan is sure that he's
winning what about that hand gesture on
the neck yeah he seems very apprehensive
yes he knows of course that he has to
win this game to keep his chances alive
but meanwhile have a seat savate body
language I don't think is looking quite
comfortable either yes and also notice
the clock yes he keeps little over two
minutes so that's not great
III and this is the thing that I was
kind of afraid of the point why I kind
of wanted to keep the King on the Kings
side is that I can protect it from any
cross from trying to eat my flowers yes
stuff from any Clause trying to eat your
flowers cross across crows so is crowd
okay now of course the crow being the
Bishop on c3 yes and your flowers being
your wonderful pawns on h6 and g5 so eat
two
hmm so now I think let's take a walk
with the king okay it's time I should I
think I should go King F - it's time yes
you get something very similar now okay
let's go ahead and see four instead okay
so you're something very similar but
instead of the pawn is on e 2 rather
than a 4 we are getting there I think
they're doing the same thing that we're
doing here and maybe let's try to take
the pawn now right
so of course Bishop takes G 5 would be
fatal for white giving black connected
passers is something you can't really do
so Bishop f8 instead and now black still
has this idea of a5 king you won but I'm
not sure what that does be 4 takes takes
whoa what if I go no I'm not so sure I
even want to take your pawn I might want
to do that idea with with a 4 but let's
continue here see a king c3 what is
white doing so it's interesting I would
like instinctively feel that this looks
suspicious for white yeah this this
looks quite dangerous as well but in
fact some but in fact you can do this
and just start pushing the pawn rights
and these pawns will be just in time to
distract this bishop from its duty and
that will be the last but crucial point
falling disaster not that this is easy
to do this right time pressure yeah
especially a calculating this this far
ahead would be a pretty ridiculous
so objectively this is a draw with king
d2 not letting the King closer and then
start pushing the pawn and it's a drop
right and no although uh derp Bobby
wasn't time pressures they have just
made move 40 so now he has half an hour
on his clock and plenty of time to to
really calculate these variation
yes but remember even when the players
Veatch move 40 the tension is still
there of course and the drama continues
absolutely
well what games have we not checked out
yet
we've seen all the a group but over in
the B group and we looked at Petrosyan
versus mihailovski no but let's take a
look at the imaan Hambleton game for a
second course as many of our viewers
clamor to see him it's a long game you
can't keep track of his Queen and keeps
disappearing it turns out that he got a
little bit too attached to having the
rook and Knight against the Queen which
is unfortunate but let's back it up a
little bit to see what happened so here
this seems like like a normal position
but there is some weak spots here which
would not attack one piece I believe
that is the greatest family fork we've
seen yes this is that oh and breaking
news vara Cobian has actually won his
game against olexander bortnik which is
what we expected after important
economists this nice Knight takes d4
tactic yes so coming back to the
Hambleton game this is indeed the
biggest family meeting that I've seen in
chess yes if only black were to play
Knight f4 the Knight takes c6 attacks
all the Flex pieces although it's not
quite as good there so you can sense how
sad a month's position is when nighty 6
would just attack everything so rook e8
must played Queen e3 you can't even push
e5 cuz then your rook is dropping okay
in d7 r okay six and what really wants
to have that family getting together
happen he's really eying the square but
one by one black has actually removed
his pieces from the attack of the Knight
takes c6
but here Gregorian comes up with this
very nice move and sadly for black Queen
sacrifice is necessary otherwise you
lose everything
with the night again yes this work just
not going away yes so Knight takes c6
and this is the part man it can get
really sad that you're trying to defend
against Knight takes c6 but you try
harder and harder for five moves and the
move that finishes you off as Knight
takes c6 in d4 takes f3 and yes this is
a lot like the zurich game that Amon
sadly had to suffer through and it's
pretty much the same deal black is
doomed to wait forever what is probably
going to be a loss black and still try
to hold and build a fortress but it
really is the question of abetik
gregorian's technique right and here
actually I think it is a bit different
than the Zerg aim all the pawns are on
the same side of the board this time
yeah but so white does have an extra
pawn and black doesn't have quite as
many squares to put this night on it's
kind of a just hanging around kind of
floating around not really a solid
outpost you know that piece but yeah I
guess the last game that we have not yet
looked at is men while Petrosyan against
Victor mihailovski and it looks like
Black has actually sacrificed in
exchange in this game but has a powerful
c3 pawn for it and also this Bishop does
good work as we see Tony rich looking
around if everything is okay and as far
as I know everything is been fairly okay
yeah yeah I haven't heard any complaints
from the players yet but yeah what's
going on here so we have this pawn
blockaded on the light squares so black
has a pawn and the bishop for the rook
rights but this bishop on d3 is kind of
useless
apart from defending the rook and the c2
Square has no active prospects as these
pawns like stone walls keep that bishop
from doing any damage to Black's
position
so I feel that this position is just
fine for me collapse key well yes nah I
I would think if anybody molesky would
be the one pushing for a win here could
be but I think it's still an exchange in
exchange is in exchange so let's say a
five at the idea of 94 yes that seems to
like the most reasonable but even there
let's say not e4 but waiting around I'm
not sure if this is this is obviously
black having the better chances but is
this over I'm not sure right no I mean
yeah once again we see these opposite
colored bishops yeah but definitely
black for choice yeah black for choice
definitely and trying and in fact
Petrosian played a three just making
sure that would never have yes cutting
off the this Black Knight but I think
this kind of reminds me of a Hungarian
tale when the Fox invites the bird for a
lunch yes and sadly nobody can eat so
it's basically a tie because you can't
really capture this rook just to explain
this story you can't really capture this
rook on a for but you know you can't
really feed on this Bishop on b2 either
okay so it's a draw understandable like
more like a positional it's what's wrong
rights okay well why don't we invite var
Cobian in for some lunch air it's do
that because that man did manage to eat
today
he won his game after a nice Knight
takes d4 tactic and why don't we get him
in the studio here to explain it all
right let's take a look at that one
so this was a game played by var a Kobe
imbed black against aleksandr bortnik
started off not surprisingly as a French
this should be for a very aggressive
setup nava days everybody plays Knight
f6 97 and c5 and it's
a normal position but a Cobian had some
sad backs against Robson in this very
very line so he decided I think to mix
it up adjust a little bit and go for
Bishop before he takes d5 and to be
honest he takes d5 got a bit of
Attraction since the Avon shook so
vastly game there so vastly one in the
World Cup and that was his biggest upset
at the moment knocking out Avant shook
but talking about a French expert we
have Varro Cobian here thank you yes I
don't think he expected the bishop
before but he spent like five six
minutes here and he took I was very
familiar with this line actually I
actually want a good game in 2017 in a
world the rapid championship begins Alec
save strong J I'm from Russia so it was
very similar so yeah so what's the
difference between this line and a
normal exchange French the night is on
c3 is that like a positive for who I
enjoy playing them for block so I don't
think it's in structure is fixed but it
still a lot of play left into all the
pieces are on the board and in
particular I think he started to go
wrong like maybe move 7 already mm-hmm
because I actually want to play f6 in
this position you're arguing for the
long side cats I want to do this c9 he
played this I don't think he was very
familiar with the ideas I you know in
order to play for the way I wanted to
play f6 Bishop a5 Queen d7 can so he
gave me a couple of temples here
actually if I'm honest yeah as far as I
know a3 is the movie reason I can take
on c3 here or I can go back even before
I 5 my game I play Bishop a5 against
Alex here tonight g7 Bishop GPA which is
a little bit like this light off and now
have six and Bishop g5 also you know it
no it's a Bishop f4 and again at some
point I will get this g5 with the planet
yeah yeah I think here this rookie one
was a really bad move because ricany one
is just misplaced index away it's not b5
idea what I think he should have done it
tonight b5 here immediately
yeah Knight b5 then I'm forced to play
Bishop a5 and he plays something like c3
mm-hmm 86 93 and then just try to bring
the knife back - would you still
consider castling long in this position
with black or not anymore I'm not sure
if I will because never before b5 comes
in with the tempo so so probably I was
just gonna I had to cast a short black
is absolutely fine here just it's just
not gonna be us lively yeah in a game
it's going to be like a slow position
okay so I have to probably like Knight
see - maybe I have to take on d3 and
take played like 98 96 like is but it's
like a normal no more boss yeah so
rookie no one I think it really bad move
in and he took a lot of lot of time here
this was like really unusual I'm sure I
counselled he spent like another 25
minutes here so he was thinking the most
of the opening and now and he got down
to really low on the clock
very early so okay once so now he played
Bishop III so as you can see now -
tempest our last Bishop Bishop g5 asleep
f4 Anna Bishop e3 after my three I
already knew our I need to just try to
play aggressively for a win so and
Possible's long time so I played g5
that's a good move and this is important
to give up the bishop because if you
play Bishop a5 it's you know it plays B
494 and there's just me free play and if
you play Bishop d6 here's Bishop here's
95 yeah and finally you could play
Knight d5 that again Soto yeah I took it
took I have to take the bishop because
he could play Bishop f1 here give me the
bishops I have to take Knight f5 enter
here this night a four-star I think is
just bad mm-hmm
I just didn't quite work out for him I
think he should he's already slightly
worship but it should play something
like maybe f3 Bishop f2
just getting into the defensive
defensive mood and just try to excite
the words clearly but but it is right
there for just didn't quite work it only
weakened the position because I play
b-66
doesn't really have an attack there yeah
and yeah like you're playing a reverse
Sicilian you're putting your king into
safety and b6 is just its aggressive me
you know a good defensive mode should be
for an hour okay Jade I bring it all my
pieces in no okay I have to make sure
out on blunder tonight c5 yeah only
trick in a position but this is again a
typical Sicilian move you don't ever get
checkmated yeah absolutely because the
king is safe in the corner Andrew babe
yeah that's why I had to play keep it
because he was already threatening 95
yeah so and now he came back again so
this was a weird game he kept trying to
do something then coming back and now
I'm you know yeah and I'm just happy no
h5 t h5 pay for he surprised me because
I didn't should play Age 3 and this is
so easy I mean I'm better here but it's
not so crystal clear here how I and he
he got down to like three seconds in
seconds
yeah really severe wanting it severe
time trouble that's big
after HD I didn't see a clear way I mean
I'm better
yeah probably so maybe I have to take
the bishop actually yeah and but it's
not so easy
he has loosened his Queen side quite a
lot yes might I might be able to even be
better in summation he played f3 a bit
too late
f3 it's our new lady again he has no
time so in her 3 mm thinking g4 was
better because he could control that f5
square which later on I had for Mike man
cuz night h4 is Bishop f2 I don't
acknowledge for does much yeah we just
have a clear target but fine so so
that's why I play g3 I think it leads
probably now I feel like it's probably
close to me when it come to shoot me so
I think I've seriously and now suddenly
Queen a5 and it's very loose his
position you have three week before this
week before is week c2 is week
everything so week yeah and he can't
really protect the position for example
if you play that Queen f2 to try to hold
a position to get an ID
water wins yeah it's the same thing as
in the game yeah double threat actually
here maybe Queen c2 is even better queen
sita's versus mia Lucinda yeah yeah you
you made it or you do Queen f3 is
winning also that's the game position in
the game server get to and this man this
was nice actually because Queen takes d4
there is one subtle move here Queen d2
and I know 22 nd - and now I'd find d4
yeah
and basically the rookie age is coming
yeah okay and out rookie one is a threat
and also rookie one so you want so c4
then you can still push and then yeah
their mates everywhere there might have
been another way I could have yeah wait
but so if a king f2 and here it's just
already losing
oh yeah execute in a seven low create
and here I just wanted to yeah you're
just winning all of the pawns
yeah I'm three pawns up just it to be
yeah a little bit precise yeah it's just
agony for ya you just played because I
guess he's not having a good tournament
and yeah a nice way to defeat the French
exchange this is how the French exchange
should be treated yes yeah I would got
the results are you just put in this
line it's you know it's so I feel
comfortable playing this position I feel
like so very nice
when and now we know how to play against
this line yeah yeah yes this Bishop you
know Bishop before and yeah probably
against 93 Bishop before is the critical
you know spend more time in yeah see if
I can play me more congratulations thank
you and hope to see a nice last round
game from you take it alright good luck
alright so let's take a look at what
Elias Mirren is doing against Alexi part
of so since then lots of have changed we
left it off at a four a six and Alex Lee
Potter have decided to go a five smearin
decided to take on a three
maybe there was an idea of keeping the
bishop but he chose to take instead king
c7 blockading the c6 pawn and freeing up
the see a truck to do whatever he'd like
to do i'll goodness ya this the son game
looking at quite a quite dangerous for
weight I didn't want to you know mention
it seems to be a day for exciting chess
you know these white players when they
played as the slightly less ambitious
lines we saw in this game al exhibit
ah've exchange on e5 rather than took
the center closed and play for you know
a serious advantage and in virus games
of course we saw the the less ambitious
it takes on d5 yes and these black
players seem to be doing quite well at
negating this kind of slightly more
boring type of chess and fighting for an
advantage even there is a good reason
why we call some lines side lines and
some lines and main lines
okay so g4 was played and in fact
smearing could have been a little bit
more accurate with rook f8 trying to
take the pawn if G takes ever happens
with the rook rights he decided to take
first rook f8 which I'm not sure I like
because why get rid of your own
beautiful pawn structure you have to and
leaving this H fun actually also a
little bit behind yes rook h1 and the
part of make sure he targets that pawn
who kept seven g5 rook d5 gauge for g7
rook d6 we have some moves played here
look at for a rook takes c6 okay so
black is finally won this pawn on d6 but
black eventually found the way to win
this one and if we're honest this is
still a fair chance for black to push
for a win because if you would take
check me I might strongly consider
getting an active King and yes we have
equal I mean you're just down upon but I
will also have a warrior king to support
my pawn
right but that you don't miss h7 pond
really makes a bad impression in this
position
I don't see why Elia chose to uh to go
for this line where he takes on G for
opening up this h-file for white yes I'm
a little bit skeptical and I'm not sure
if that's objectively the best I still
would have preferred route Cafe eight
and maybe take later yeah I definitely
agree so this is where we stand
currently I guess rook takes c6 has just
been played and Alex have stopped nots
to decide what he's going to do about
this I certainly don't like this line
with blacks active King yeah right here
so I kind of feel that in the long term
black has real chances as this King if
that King ever gets a chance to take
this pawn I think those are real winning
chances for Elias Marin definitely so
what can we do to try let's say you
don't really want to move your rook
because that would give free reign for
this one could even go c4 or just rookie
five trying to win this pawn and this
King might get into some danger that
both rooks entering the position it's
looking a little bit suspicious there
yes
so in fact King d2 makes the most sense
like an go King b7 just waiting and it's
not that easy to make a useful move here
for white right and for black I think
he's actually making a threat here of
rook d6 followed by rook d5 hitting this
Jeep on either that or checks so if I
make a random move I might check you oh
yes take and go here and take this guy
okay so a lot of things to look out for
yeah so oh four four right here
Julius Miren so far showed some very
nice fine technical chests in my fee
going on the streak if he wins today
absolutely this win would bring him to
+1 and having a very decent tournament
after all yes which fit one more round
to go all right so let's see if
Lenderman did manage to squeeze some
advantage out of that bishop and game
okay where do we stand here so we
started from this position look see one
was played King f3 King g7 and f4 and
basically the same plan that I was
suggesting and white eventually there
wants to go E 4 E 5 or g4 g5 right
so Bishop d8 Lenderman chose efore h4
thing is you don't want to go g4 because
then the black squares might get super
weak I might even go g5 if I want to and
setting up my just a dark square block
here just as R Square D ok then it
should be an easy draw so G takes h4 as
logical takes e5 and this is still kind
of uncomfortable to defend with black
but honestly it still revolves around
equal especially as this rook is just
this would he want some pressure on that
c4 room and someone feels like it's well
in hand for black and yang white also
does have to be careful if he wants to
bring his king up the board as well
there's no an H pawn to look out for
need at least one of your pieces to kind
of hang back to defend that guy yes I
would assume that this game is likely to
endure but talking about opposite
colored bishop and games yes how is our
game of the day doing in a group so we
have some moves this has been played
since them so II two of us played Bishop
C 3 kg 6 so black didn't go for the long
walk to a3 but decided to go to g6 yeah
fair enough
considering how when we actually put
that line on the board and it seemed as
though white had just enough to a draw
that game so your then decided that he
is going to go here and attack the pawns
frontally interesting caps 3 h5 King F 2
black is basically calling the shots and
to rob Ali can only wait and see what
happens there should be 6
getting at 3 Bishop d7 they should be
too so white choosing not to take on e 2
and it is black upon that's a both past
and farther away from the Queen side
yeah this definitely makes sense because
the farther away the pawns are for black
the more winning chances he can kind of
generate is this winning not a hundred
percent sure but why would you go for
this if you don't have to exactly and so
far I'm not sure how black will make any
progress here because you can be quite
difficult after all yeah you whenever
you would go the other way in now I'll
just go back and take that pawn perhaps
a black will will in fact play H takes G
H takes G and then start going this this
other way maybe you start with King f6
instead of a king f7 just to give myself
one extra time turn oh yeah I will play
King e7
and yet King d6 is my plan and okay you
are getting you are getting this pawn
over here and I'm just nowhere near in
time to do much yeah and I will just
take and go Bishop e7 because I'm happy
to give up my bishop for upon yeah you
do get to take this pawn with check on
g4 but then unfortunately no way to
defend this pawn for black yes
so that pawn must fall I have just too
much pressure on this square and there's
no way to win this shaping up to be a
draw it looks yes and that's a little
bit of a heartbreaker for Yordan as he
had a big advantage in the opening was
up upon had some pressure but somehow
this game fizzled into draw because drew
by Lee put up some stiff defenses yes
and that is great news for Rey Robson
who will actually be the group 8
champion he will clinch it if Jordan
forest cannot win this game and that's
pretty much where we stand in the a
group why don't we take another quick
look at the B group and before we how
they're doing
yes that is the question of course this
game is still critical for the group II
standings if Dennis does win this game
Jack will fall a full half point behind
ya circus out of Perez who is currently
his co-leader who's in number two its
jack so right now we have yasser Quesada
Prez and Jackson Bulli AK they came into
today with five points
out of seven yes sir has already drawn
his game putting him at five and a half
so now Jack sits at five out of seven if
he draws this he will move to tied for
first with yes sir if he loses this he
stays a half point behind and then the
third player to worry about that we've
been talking about is a romhack Obion he
is also going to be at five out of eight
after today
his game has already been decided so he
will be also looking to chase Yassir
tomorrow so he would still be in clear
set I mean a tight second place aiming
to catch
Quezada yes absolutely so what will be
the pairings tomorrow well why don't we
you know wrap up our thoughts on this
game first make sure that Dennis is
actually still winning don't want to
count our chickens yet before they've
hatched that's true so what's going on
in fact this looks like the beginning of
the end right yes both the doors here he
does seem to have this idea of a queen
c3 over to f3 checkmating that that
white king pretty convincingly and the
disc Queen just a move away from helping
to checkmate is unfortunately not enough
because black gets to go there first to
slow after all and cod rich would pull
up a big upset which will have a
profound influence on this whole
tournament
absolutely well why don't we hear from a
quick word from Ryan Chester about some
golden tickets he has a golden
opportunity for you Vera's at home
hi my name is Ryan Chester and I'm the
development manager for the Saint Louis
chess club I'm here to tell everyone
about a golden opportunity that we have
right now we're selling golden tickets
for $50 a piece it's a 50-50 raffle
$5,000 will go to the Scholastic chess
initiative for the st. Louis chess club
and $5,000 will go to a lucky winner
we're only selling 200 of these and
we've already sold many to grandmasters
and all of our commentary team as well
so if you're interested please call the
Chess Club or go to our website on the
homepage and buy a golden ticket there
thank you and good luck
[Music]
yeah welcome back to the fall chess
classic of course a wonderful
opportunity to support some scholastic
chess support chess in the schools and
get a chance to win some money for
yourself with a $5,000 grand prize in
those golden tickets time is running out
we are running short on tickets and
short on time those tickets are going to
be pulled September 30th and I don't
smoke can yes get it and with that in
mind why don't we take another quick
look at this durable event forest game
because this is the key game for the day
it is all writing on this position
whether or not Rhea Robson will be named
the fall chess classic group a champion
or if he still has some work to do
tomorrow so remember what I said when I
looked at the players note your than
forest gestures where is his hands at he
does not seem happy let's take a look at
the players yes so we see Jordan not
even bothering to hold his head up on
his own yes he needs the help from his
hands he did have his hands on his neck
but clearly both players are kind of
waiting for the other person signal yeah
waiting for the action really break out
yeah at some point I we expect black to
really make a decision here at the
moment he's kind of shuffling around
kind of not showing his hand but
eventually he is going to have to give
up something on the Kings side or the
Queen side I understand from that look
on the orden this looks like the sign
that I'm still trying but at heart I
gave up right and meanwhile massif
actually seems a little bit more relaxed
he's just moving his pieces back and
forth he knows that whatever will happen
will happen he simply has to wait for
your Dhin to make the call yes but as
far as I can see your than is still
trying to make some progress even though
it's very hard to do so but
it's never too too late to pull out
miracle yeah well we're going to be
staying here covering this game covering
the other games until it is decided
whether or not Jordan can do this can
win this game talking about some other
exciting and games let's go back to
Ilyas Marans games of course it Pato
some moves has been played and he kind
of left off a troop g4 it's somewhat
riders like capture this pawn on Stokes
why decided to take on c6 tasting well
this was not the line that we expected
yes it seemed as though the black king
was going to maneuver his way into us
and very accurate Ori in fact a pot off
had the same issues therefore he
maneuvered the rook to c8 to stop that
very idea interesting look at faking the
five no rookie six just defending this
pawn I have a feeling that black I'm not
even sure what he's trying to do maybe
rook c6 and King c4 yeah that would make
sense um also something that would make
sense to me is if he somehow managed to
get this King to f5 and trying to take
this Jeep on away yes another thing
would make a lot of sense only issue I
would see there as you go King g5 let's
add pass right for the moment check you
it's unavailable due to this check but
I'm trying to make something work say
you do play king d2 and I play something
like rook d6 there and the point is if
you ever play this rook c5 check I was
hoping I could play something along the
lines of rook d5 and yet now King f5 and
you might take my a pawn and get a
powerful past a pawn for yourself but I
will now have connected passers on the
Kings side that's true but you do need
to be super careful with my pawn yes it
is further than any of your pawns okay I
like it I like it for black okay so King
takes g5 here is this the winning
endgame in fact
this turns out to be very good for a
white and as I'm going to win the beep
on so you also get connected pastors by
yourself and then I guess black is going
to find himself in quite a bit of
trouble so let's go back to this
position let's try to make a better move
down King d2 sorry okay he's six okay
I'll give a check I must come back go
back
so if you ever go here I go okay eight
rights so it's not quite as clear how
smearin will make progress yeah I don't
really see the point in Black's play
thus far Ruki six I wasn't happy about
yeah honestly in that position we just
saw I wanted to play Ricky seven for
black yeah but yeah then of course
there's this problem of Rick AAA to
really look out for yes so this rook is
super active also probably this rook c8
maneuver was nice by it pots off as this
king would take a lot of time taking
that pawn and if this pawn drops Mike
gets real counter play definitely
actually there was a move played by
Elias Miran he went rookie six check
King d6 and now he part of went back and
again the same deal and maybe King C or
King D seven is required for black
hitting this work on C eight then again
I can do what we hated the first time
that white can actually start harassing
this pump right interesting and if Ricky
seven there's Rick a8 and all of a
sudden your rule is just switching sides
of the board effortlessly causing Y
depending but you're not winning right
so King D seven but maybe let's say rook
c5 giving up this fun but dreaming of
the same scenarios of walking up it just
seems worse though white wouldn't a
black I played Ricky five while his King
was on d5 rather than now when it's get
some decent that would be nicer just
doesn't make as much sense to me I
really want to go here yeah Rick a it
takes takes Kingdom d5
the king being so active and it's
definitely far superior than the line we
saw yeah King on this is something that
I would like with black even if you're
not winning there's a fair chance and in
fact that's what smearing does yeah but
honestly this this has to just be a
worse variation than playing rookie 5
immediately instead of this Rob 6 move
probably so maybe a missed chance there
from familias Marin yeah but there's
still some chances here and it's not
quite sure I'm not quite sure if this is
will end in a draw
I think Ilyas Mirren will push this and
we'll have real chances of winning this
I mean in a while in the ordinal on
forest game nothing spectacular happened
yet just lots of Bishop maneuvering as
you're done fun for us is looking around
yes looking for a sign maybe that's
something that can show him the the way
the way to win this the very difficult
bishop endgame what not much has changed
he did exchange a pawns a pair of bonds
on g4 Bishop c3 say King g6 Bishop d2
let's make a run for it takes a five
let's say what happens if Bishop e7 yeah
you have to play King c4 and and at the
end of event you are for strong
eventually sacrifice your bishop for
this jeep on and oh there's just nothing
doing here yeah so objectively a drawn
position forests can still try to come
up with some neat little tricks but is
there anything substantial there I doubt
it well why don't we take a look at this
a veteran gorian versus a mon Hambleton
game some changes have been made to this
position since the last time we looked
you know notably a set of rooks is off
the board and the White King has
advanced all the way up the board to age
five
and there we see actually both players
seem to be under quite a bit of stress
yeah trying to figure this one out so
let's see Brooke a7 was played a pair of
rooks was just exchanged takes Queen a
for just putting pressure on that rook
rook e7 King f2 and the King March I
like where your White has done here
there's no need to rush anything at all
just get your king to the best possible
square get your queen to the best
possible square before making your your
your breakthrough you're moving king g4
night f8 so this is why we talk about
the famous game short teaming because
you never know when you actually
capitalize on the fact that you knew
about this idea right and once again it
makes a lot more sense and games like
these yes then in most middle game
positions like that where we saw at
night that of course is a game but some
patterns are more than useful yeah of
course
so here um you have to imagine the way
that white is eventually going to break
through is with a push of a pond perhaps
this e4 to e5 breakthrough is the way
that a white is looking to really shake
loose the black King yeah create some
some serious threats so it's not that
notice that there's no I don't think
there's 96 because of f5 yeah that would
cause some problems but yes maybe
there's no key 5 actually Erika doesn't
beat but ah again now the e5 break works
oh because here I take it there's no
more efile square yes and now everything
falls apart yeah this FB 5 and then not
really wanting to recapture on e5 but
simply play f5 to you know take away the
the necessary squares from Plex in fact
a mom did play Knight g6 hoping maybe
this would actually happen and then so
if black actually gets this structures
there is some hope of holding no it's my
I'm actually just be a draw this looks
like a very very
a basic fortress actually but also does
show this to mr. Magnus Carlsen because
he wouldn't like to hear the end result
of this game of course not
but that's a that's a bit a bit of a
dream world for black I don't think
that's what's going on but in fact in
this position mr. Magnus Carlsen is
correct as he five is coming and has
five and this is a win so there is
indeed no fortresses in addition to that
white doesn't even need to play e5 here
if I've might be a the easiest way to
win the game but if white sees something
he doesn't like if you see some ghost
that he doesn't like you can just play a
simple move and keep the game going keep
his chances of life mm-hmm so what else
is going on I think some more changes
have happened in that other game between
men well Petrosyan and Victor
mihailovski it looks there as well a set
of Brooks has been traded off the set of
rooks has been traded off and did that
change a lot no it's still a deadlock so
let's move into the cartridge game where
cod rich messed up oh no actually he
didn't okay for a second thought he did
he actually didn't go for Queen c3 just
played Queen d3 now it has exactly the
same effect yes just aiming at these
light squares aiming at every aiming at
that Prince if he's perused the players
and how they take the stress of chess
let's have a close-up on these players
as well yeah you see a Jackson Billy Ike
really under a lot of pressure here he's
down to just two minutes on his clock
and this is after the time control so
there's no extra time coming Jack's way
and he is looking to be unable to solve
his many many problems in the solution
also look at these two great sportsmen
as both his papa papa poker face hooker
faces okay they don't seem to be too
concerned about the position obviously
they are but they are not showing any
sign
of regret yes we do see a couple moves
played they're actually white going for
a seven and black going for rook a -
just keeping an eye on this pawn and
really taking away White's threats here
yeah and in fact this is the only moment
you can see Jack Stamboul iakh resigning
himself to his fate yeah I think we
should just stay here it looks as though
checkmate is imminent yes yes Queen f3
is coming Queen f3 and now with the rook
over on the a file after King a or King
f1 there is simply rook a1 with an
immediate checkmate nothing really left
for Jack to do but I take these last
couple minutes maybe start to cope with
the fact that I looked away yes news in
the a group our key matchup for the day
the only one that matters for the first
place standing has been decided Jordan
Vaughn forest has drawn his game against
massif Dhirubhai Lee and with this huge
momentous result Rey Robson is
officially going to be the group a
champion actuations classic
congratulations to Rey $6,000 grand
prize as well as the honor the bragging
rights of 2019 polish champion and
really it's been an outstanding
tournament right I mean well deserved
winning five games in the middle of the
tournament is a rare feat that you can
hardly achieve and only the best of the
best can do that yeah yeah it took him a
couple rounds to settle in but once he
did he played some astoundingly accurate
chess he deserved pretty much all of
those went all of those five wins he
just played better than his opponents
throughout this event and in fact in
some of the games he was relentless as
we saw the position that he had against
var Akopian but it all seemed to close
down the position and very very hard to
crack but in the end they found a way to
break through a g4 and managed to win
that game as well which was critical
well congratulations to ranked
congratulations Jordan as well who has
also played a very excellent tournament
really tried his best to make something
of this game but
the opposite color bishops it was just
impossibly it was a well-played game by
both through our by Leon fun forest it's
not without mistakes but at a high state
game it's normal to have some ups and
downs happening well with this result
why don't we take a look at all of the
results in Group A today and see them
where we stand
Alexandre Lenderman is still fighting it
out against Dario spirits that game we
do expect to be a draw
Alexandre bortnik has lost to vara
Cobian who came in to explain a very
nice win in the French defense their
friend Alex at the table is defending
against Ilyas Mirren and it looks there
may be some missed chances in that game
it'll be interesting to see what that
result turns out to be ray Robson had an
early draw today against grant Malcolm
young and then massif Dhirubhai Lee has
drawn his game against Jordan van forest
spoiling his chances at catching ray
Robson in the final round making ray
Robson our group a tournament champion
and over in the B group ironic Obion I
believe has won his game against
Stephens err or no I'm sorry these are
was that game was Steven Zurich playing
Alexander fear X so I got a little bit
of mixed up there so fear has won his
game against Steven xeric today and I
believe those were those are the round
seven round eight yes so give us a just
a moment to pull those up here of course
you know Alexander fear played a very
nice game today very nice to be he's
found his form in this tournament if he
had found this this type of form this
type of chess that he's playing just a
few rounds earlier maybe we talking we'd
be talking about him playing for the
championship he did play the game of the
day today finding some very very
original playing some very original
chess and that's not really surprising
from a player who plays the Kings gambit
right well I do want to remind you guys
tomorrow due to the opportunity for
playoffs the rounds will be starting a
couple hours early the round itself
starts at 11:00 a.m. if you want to get
up and follow along for yourself on us
chess champs calm and our show will be
coming to you live at 1:30 p.m.
is 1:30 p.m. to join us for coverage of
the final rounds maybe we can pull up
those round 8 results or at least the
round 8 pairings and ok take me take a
look for the the big groups results and
actually many many important things have
happened in these past couple of minutes
here in the B group Steven zerk has lost
to Alexander fear
Alexander fear once again finding his
form in this tournament a better
Gregorian is up a queen and a pawn for a
rook in a night against Amon Hamilton
and looking to be like he can break
through that fortress for him on men
while Petrosyan has officially now drawn
his game against objections Emily ik
went down to Dennis camp yes Dennis CAD
rich playing the spoiler in this group
be spoiling Jack's most of Jack's
chances at winning this championship
jack of course can still catch up to
yessir tomorrow with with a good win in
the final rounds and a rom hack ho bian
has drawn his game with Yasser Quesada
Perez Iram moves to five out of eight
also just a half point out of the lead
going into this final around so it's
shaping up like it's going to be an
exciting day of action tomorrow Dennis
what do you expect from this B group
which of these three players do you
think is but never let's take a look at
the pairings for nine or at least the at
least the results for this round I mean
these standings uh understandings I'm
not sure if we you don't actually we
don't have those ready to bring up yeah
I can just read them off here for ya be
great so yes er case nada Perez in the B
group is currently the B group leader
with five and a half out of eight
chasing him are two players Jack
Stamboul e AK and a romhack Obion both
on five out of eight and then not
mathematically eliminated are both
manuel petrosyan and dennis CAD rich
both on plus one four and a half out of
eight but they would need a yes or
quesada to lose his game tomorrow for
them to even have a chance at a playoff
in fact yes circus ah that will be white
so if he wants to make sure that he wins
the tournament yes must go all out for
the win yeah with a draw he would secure
his spot in a playoff but definitely
nothing is guaranteed if you go to rapid
tight
yes so I would be expecting tiebreaks
yeah it's shaping up like there's a very
good chance of that actually occurring
of course so many sorry so many players
playing so well I see there's a big
chance of even a more is even a
three-way tie break yeah it's certainly
possible of course we will be joining
you tomorrow like I said starting at
1:30 p.m. two hours earlier than our
start time for the rest of this event
and we will be sticking around until
everything is decided until the
conclusion of this B group has been
decided be sure to join us once again
tomorrow live at 1:30 p.m. with that in
mind thank you all very much for joining
us here today for our coverage of the
2019 fall chess classic and make sure to
join us tomorrow for the final round who
will be the champion in the B group will
it be yes sir Perez will appear raha
Cobian will it be Jack shouldn't Bulli
AK will it be one of the further away
chasers nobody knows you will have to
join us tomorrow for our final round of
the 2019 fall chess classic or that be
there this has been a presentation of
the st. Louis chess club
you
you